how it started and how it's going
flipper zero flipper zero is known as
the Tamagotchi for hackers and Geeks the
project appeared in 2020 and exploded on
Kickstarter raising one million dollars
in just a day and a half the tool was
designed as a multi-tool to control all
appliances in the home as well as Store
electronic keys and cards the greatest
strength of flipper was that it can
protect copy and reproduce signals so
how is it going now this hacking tool
has gone viral on Tick Tock flipper xero
has received mixed reviews for some it's
a dangerous tool with which you can
steal personal data in an instant and
for others it's a cool toy that can
alert companies to vulnerabilities in
their systems according to the documents
the manufacturers say that flipper 0 is
legal but more and more countries and
companies have questions about it
because its nature as open source
software that everyone can make changes
to can turn flipper zero into a
universal lockpick for hackers what do
you think what's the future for this
device leave your opinions in the
comments below